cartoon characters are able to take us
in a completely different world and
allow us to explore our imagination as
well as enjoy their antics the debate of
who's the best cartoon character is
never ending but today we'll explore
which cartoon character looks the best
as a teenager wait till you see patrick
Star don't forget to subscribe to our
Channel and give this video a big thumbs
up now join us as we check out ten
cartoon characters reimagined as
teenagers minions let's start with just
a bit of ridiculous fun the minions have
taken over the world when they appeared
in the very first despicable meet back
in 2010 they became insanely popular and
you either love them or totally hate
them we're not sure how old these yellow
creatures actually are but it's safe to
say that they're gibberish and
shenanigans make them seem like they're
children
so where do minions actually come from
well no one's quite sure some say
they've evolved from a single yellow
cell organism and others claim they're a
result of a DNA mutation so what would
the minions look like as teenagers an
online fashion retailer called sty light
gave minions a fashionable makeover we
believe this is what at least one of
them would look like as a teenager
we can totally see a minion rocking long
blonde hair and replace the denim
overalls with stylish rock concert
clothes maybe this makeover could help
win back those who aren't big fans of
these crazy yellow creatures here are a
couple of other times minions decided to
dress up in Despicable Me 2 this minions
dressed as Pippi Longstocking and here
they are posing as Super Mario Brothers
characters we do think that the rocker
outfit and long blonde hair makes them
look just a little bit older but we bet
that they'd act crazy no matter how old
they are Donald Duck Donald Duck isn't
regularly featured on our channel so
let's dedicate some time to this iconic
character who doesn't love Donald Duck
did you know that Donald Duck made its
first appearance back in 1934 that's
more than 80 years ago the character has
come a long way since then
and he remains one of the most iconic
Disney characters ever did you know that
his middle name is Fauntleroy and he has
an official twin sister called dum Bella
and he even has a meme called dolan
check out this illustration done by a
deviantART user Doki Nana it features a
slightly older looking Donald Duck with
the Dolan meme as his companion although
Donald has kids and a job it's hard to
believe he's so old
his meme on the other hand might as well
be a child Dolan also known as uncle
Dolan was created by a Finnish artist
who featured the badly
Donald Duck character in a series of
comics with terrible grammar the craze
started in 2010 and these comics were
created in ms paint but dolan is still
popular in the meme world and it even
got an HD comic upgrade still we have to
admit we do prefer the regular version
of Donald Duck if you want to watch just
one more video the premium is the
platform where you should go get early
access to videos from the things the
taco the trendy the richest and many
other great channels in one place with
ad free browsing click this link to sign
up for free to the premium and get ready
to binge watch videos from your favorite
channels Mickey Mouse speaking of Donald
Duck let's also talk about Mickey Mouse
the very first Mickey Mouse cartoon
called Steamboat Willie first appeared
in 1928 and you can still see the
tribute in many other Disney movies it's
what started the whole disneymania and
skyrocketed Walt Disney into the world
of fame yes Mickey Mouse is actually
pretty old he's also the first cartoon
character to get an actual star on the
Hollywood Walk of Fame and it's all well
deserved as the face of Disney Mickey
Mouse is one of the most recognizable
characters ever we all know Mickey as a
mouse but what would he look like as an
actual teenager Mickey Mouse as a human
is always an interesting topic to debate
but we absolutely love this deviantART
users portrayal of Mickey as a teen we
are in love with his hoodie
Mickey's iconic voice developed through
the years and belonged to several people
from actual Walt Disney Jimmy McDonald
and Wayne Alwine to brett Iowan who is
the voice of Mickey as of 2009 over the
years we got to learn more and more fun
facts about Mickey did you know that
Felicity Fieldhouse is actually his
older sister and she first appeared in
1932 and then there are of course the
relationship goals between Mickey and
the ever so Charming Minnie Mouse Minnie
Mouse we always talk about Disney
Princesses but it's time to pay
attention to one of the most underrated
female Disney characters Minnie and
Mickey have that forever love that all
Disney romantics want Minnie Mouse
deserves more recognition and not only
because she's just so adorable there are
tons of facts many don't know about this
iconic Mouse did you know that Walt
Disney wanted to name Minnie Mortimer at
first but his wife convinced him to go
with Minnie Mouse Thank You Lillian
Disney Minnie has often described her
ideal man as someone who can make her
laugh and it's safe to say that Mickey
exceeds her
spectating did you know that their
marriage was never revealed on-screen
walt disney mentioned they're married in
private
check out this younger version of minnie
reimagined as a human teenager doesn't
she look adorable Mickey and Minnie are
cute as cartoon characters but they'd
also look extremely good as a teenage
couple check out her awesome hair
speaking of fun facts about Minnie did
you know that her full name is Minerva
and Walt Disney was actually Minnie's
original voice from 1929 to 1946 because
he didn't like any of the voice actors
for the role he finally chose the
actress Russi Taylor who actually
married Wayne Alwine who voiced a Mickey
talking about relationship goals
Rainbow Dash My Little Pony was the show
that unexpectedly took over the world
and captured the hearts of many with a
motto friendship is magic my little pony
shares the story of seven main
characters Rainbow Dash is one of the
most popular and recognizable of the
bunch
her cute look is topped with an
awesome-looking rainbow mane and tail
she's the one that's in charge of the
weather and always makes sure a
Ponyville is full of clear skies and
rainbows a deviant art user called
little breeze took her character to a
new level and reimagined her as a
teenager a human version of Rainbow Dash
still sports rainbow hair we loved how
the artist added the blue and turned her
into a friendly looking punk rocker
speaking of my little pony
did you know that it all started when a
large doll called my pretty pony
released in 1982 a year later they
shrunk the collection and turned it into
the ponies we know today when the first
cartoon aired in 1986 it was heavily
marketed to a female demographic we bet
that never in a million years did the
company think it would ever reach a
brand new fandom that would call
themselves the bronies we'd love to see
all my little pony characters reimagined
as humans Lilly loud we've done several
videos on the loud house but never paid
attention to the youngest of the loud
family Lilly loud is just 15 months old
but the fans are already a reimagining
what she would look like as a teenager
Lilly is pretty much happy most of the
time and no one really likes when she
cries sounds like a typical baby doesn't
it well at 15 months old Lilly is
already learning how to be independent
and talk following in her sister Lisa's
footsteps to become a pretty smart kid
she appears to be less tomboyish than
some of her other sisters which is why
this illustration makes total sense it
belongs to a deviantART user Jay boy 32x
and he reimagined a teenaged Lilly to
look a lot like her older sisters if
you've watched our other loud house
videos you know the characters were
first imagined as rabbits which is why
teenage Lilly is also sporting a bunny
like to since all other characters from
the loud family come with different
skills and personalities we wonder which
talents will Lily have in the future
with the new seasons of the loud house
coming soon it's safe to say we'll be
able to see Lily grow up along with
everyone else on the show we just
thought we'd give you an interesting
sneak peek from a talented artist
Powerpuff Girls and who can forget about
the Powerpuff Girls the show featuring
three girls with superpowers was first
released on Cartoon Network in 1994
although the plot of the show was highly
unique the creator of the show had no
idea it would become this popular Craig
McCracken created the concept for
Powerpuff Girls back when he was in high
school back then their name was slightly
pg-13 rated and had to be changed for
something slightly cuter the Powerpuff
Girls were so popular the animators
could play around with all sorts of plot
lines including reimagining them as
teenagers in season 5 the Powerpuff
Girls are shown as what they look like
as teenagers in an episode called the
city of Clips pill we know the girls are
mostly short but as teenagers they're
actually pretty tall their hair is
longer and like most teenage girls
they're wearing quite a lot of makeup
craig mccracken was surprised the show
was able to reach such audience even
though this looks like a kids show it's
the dialogue that makes it also
appropriate for adults the girls are
totally sassy and there are so many
hidden innuendos in the show it really
is instantly lovable and we have to say
we love the Powerpuff Girls
even as teenagers Bart Simpson The
Simpsons fans this one's for you as the
oldest child in the Simpsons family the
10 year old Bart is known to always be
up to no good
also known as el barto and Bart man Bart
is one of the most popular characters on
the show his antics are constantly
causing him to get distracted in school
which usually lands him in detention who
can forget about the iconic blackboard
scene at the beginning of the show known
as the chalkboard gags Bart wrote
hundreds of sentences during his
detention
these range from sentences like the
capital of Montana is not Hannah and I
will not flip the classroom upside down
it gave us a good idea that Bart isn't a
good kid like his sister but that's
precisely why so many people loved him
in an episode called Bart hood we're
shown what Bart would look like as a
teenager we get to see that his
troublemaking attitude hasn't really
changed through the years but he did
become much more handsome have you ever
wondered why the characters on the show
are all yellow Matt graining the creator
of the show stated he wanted to catch
the attention of those who simply flick
through their TV channels it's safe to
say his trick definitely worked The
Simpsons is the longest-running cartoon
show and
20:19 it's set to become the
longest-running TV show ever Mike
Wazowski speaking of favorite cartoon
characters Mike Wazowski also tends to
be the most recognizable out of everyone
on monsters Inc in the very first movie
Mike is a cowardly creature who always
manages to steal every scene he's in his
personality really develops in monsters
University and he went from a somewhat
cowardly creature to a determined and
headstrong eighteen-year-old scarer who
would have thought the world could fall
in love with this lime green monster but
the truth is he's among some of the
favorite Disney characters out there
check out what he looked like as an
actual teenager at monsters University
we love his lime-green hair and he'd
really make a handsome man did you know
that Mike Wazowski actually had cameos
in Finding Nemo wall-e and several other
Disney movies Billy Crystal the actor
who voices Mike was the reason why Mike
and Sulley have such chemistry on and
off screen the actors are one of the few
that actually recorded their dialogue
together Mike is one of our favorite
characters but he's also a favorite
character Billy has ever voiced during
his acting career did you know that his
granddaughter's actually call him
grandpa Mike Wazowski the teenage Mike
looks awesome but Billy Crystal really
is the perfect version of an adult Mike
Wazowski in human form of course Patrick
Starr we've had a chance to highlight
several spongebob squarepants characters
on our channel but now it's time to talk
about the most popular starfish of the
cartoon world Patrick Starr is lazy
naive and somewhat dim-witted
but we still love him he has some of the
best one-liners on the show and you
could always count on Patrick to do
something that will move forward the
entire plot as SpongeBob's best friend
he's extremely loyal but even their
friendship has some questionable moments
here's Patrick as an actual teenager he
still looks just as happy-go-lucky and
we love his purple shirt Patrick is
voiced by Bill fogger Bucky who said he
sounds like a big goofball
so playing Patrick came almost naturally
we're not sure how old Patrick is and
even though he lives on its own it's
hard to believe he's actually an adult
bill mentioned his antics are mostly a
result of studying the insanity and
imagination of his own children he'd
simply attach himself to their
imagination and see what happens
the cast of spongebob also records the
episodes together which is why the show
is so energetic and crazy just like its
characters out of all spongebob
squarepants characters which one is your
favorite don't be try to tell us what
you think in the comment section down
below and that's it for the 10 cartoon
characters reimagined as teenagers for
more videos like this one check out
kids who look like cartoon characters
see you next time
[Music]